[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
وتونس الاسرائيليه تقتحم نابلس 10 قتلى
و50 جريحا فلسطينيا على الاقل
انفراجه اقتصاديه في اليمن وديعه سعوديه
جديده بمليار دولار والريال اليمني يبدا
التعافي
الكويت تغربل المجمعات التجاريه ازمه سوق
شرق تتجدد والحكومه تتسلم مجمع المثنى
رابع كذلك
[موسيقى]
احتفاء شعبي ورسمي بيوم التاسيس في
السعوديه اعتزاز بذكرى وتاريخ الدول
السعوديه الثلاث
حياكم الله اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
مقتلها تسعه واصابه نحو 100 اخرين برصاص
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها البلده
القديمه في مدينه نابلس واوضحت في بيان ان
الكثير من الحالات مصابه بالرصاص الحي
بينما اصيب اكثر من 250 بالاقتناق وانسحبت
القوات الاسرائيليه من البلده القديمه في
نابلس بعد اقتحامها حرس الشيخ مسلم وسط
اطلاق نار كثيف
يجري الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم
محادثات في وارسو مع اعضاء مجموعه بوخارست
تسعه والتي تضم دول الجناح الشرقي لحلف
الناتو ومن المقرر ان يجدد الرئيس بايدن
خلال لقاءاته التاكيد على دعم اوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا وعلى دعم بلاده الثابت
للجناح الشرقي في حلف شمال الاطلسي مجموعه
بوخارست تسعه تضم اعضاءا في حلف الناتو من
شرقي ووسط اوروبا واغلبها دول كانت تنتمي
الى الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
من الرياض ما الذي يمكن ان نعرفه عن خلفيه
هذا الاجتماع بين الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ومجموعه بوخارست 9
اهلا بك انا في البدايه الوفود المشاركه
في هذا الاجتماع بدات بالتوافد الى هنا
الى القصر الرئاسي البولندي حيث
يبدا الاجتماع في هذا القصر الذي يظهر
خلفي في الصوره الاجتماع سيبدا بعد حوالي
نصف ساعه من الان ربما انسحب من الصوره كي
تشاهدوا
المواكب السياره للوفود المشاركه وهي تدخل
الى القصر الرئاسي البولندي تشارك في هذا
الاجتماع الذي يحضره طبعا الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن والامين العام لحلف النيتو
تشارك كل من
هنغاريا رومانيا بولندا استونيا ليتوانيا
وكذلك تشيكيا وسلوفاكيا
وبلغاريا مجموعه بوخارست بل بوخارست التي
تضم هذه الدول كانت انشئت عام
2015 تحديدا في شهر نوفمبر ردا على غزو
روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم ثم ضمها لهذه
الجزيره
ونشات مجموعه بوخارست تسعه بمبادره من
الرئيسين الروماني كلاوس المهندس
والبولندي
هذا
الاجتماع اذا سيبدا بعد حوالي نصف ساعه من
الان الرئيس الامريكي سيؤكد على حرصي
بلاده على تعزيز الشراكه الامنيه السياسيه
العسكريه والاقتصاديه مع الدول المذكوره
سيدعوها الى اتخاذ مواقف تتلائم مع تغيرات
دوليه حاصله في العالم سيطلب منهم ان
يعيدوا النظر في بعض سياساتهم كي تتلائم
مع ضروره مواجهه ليس فقط التحدي الروسي بل
ايضا مع التحدي الصين كقوه الصاعده وطبعا
هو سيستمع الى ما يطلبه هؤلاء هذه الدول
التسعه التي ذكرتها نايف توجد بعض
التباينات بين اعضائها فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الواجب اتخاذه من النزاع الدائر في
اوكرانيا اي بين اوكرانيا وروسيا هذه
الدول ستحاول خلال هذا الاجتماع تنسيق
مواقفها تمهيدا اللي قمه الناتو التي
ستنعقد في فيلينيوس عاصمه ليتوانيا في
الحادي عشر والثاني عشر من شهر حزيران
يونيو المقبل نايف حسين يعني ما هي
السياسات التي من المتوقع ان يتم الاتفاق
عليها بين مجموعه بوخارست 9 والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في ضوء هذه الازمه
الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه والتي يعني هي
على اعتاب اكمال عامها الاول
سيشرح الرئيس الامريكي كيف ان بلاده حشر
ضد حشدت الدعم الدولي في جميع المجالات
لاوكرانيا وسيطلب من هذه الدول دعما
سيتعهد بان بالالتزام بتجديد الالتزام
الامريكي بحمايه امن الدول الاعضاء في حلف
النيتو ولكن ايضا بحمايه الدول
المتحالفه مع هذه التباينات من بينها مثلا
ان بعض الدول التي ذكرتها ليست متحمسه
كثيرا
لفكره الدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا على سبيل
المثال انا تحدثت عن الدول المشاركه
بلغاريا تشيكيا سلوفاكيا لتوانيا استونيا
بولندا رومانيا من بين هذه الدول مثلا
هناك هنغاريا التي يعتمد رئيس وزراءها
فيكتور اورمان خطا متشددا جدا لناحيه رفض
المساعده العسكريه
لاوكرانيا ضد روسيا لا ننسى ان هذه الدول
التسع كانت فيما مضى اعضاء في الكتله
الشرقيه التي كانت تنضوي تحت اسم حلف
وارسو المؤيد للاتحاد السوفيتي السابق في
مواجهه حلف الناتو ومن المفارقات ان هذه
الدول التسعه التي كانت اعضاء في حلف
وارسو الذي يدور في فلك الاتحاد السوفيتي
سابقا باتت الان تدور في فلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وباتت وارسو واجهه ليس
للحلف المؤيد للاتحاد السوفيتي السابق بل
باتت وباجهه لحلف الناتو الحلف الخصم
للحلف الذي كان يحمل اسم حلف وارسو اخيرا
لو سمحت لي بلغاريا ايضا لديها تحفظات على
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا ربما لا تصل لحجم
التحفظ الذي تعبر عنه
هنغاريا ولكن بلغاريا ايضا لا تريد الدخول
في نزاع عسكري وتتجنب دعم
الاوكراني عسكريا نايف اذا تباين مواقف
ربما
سنتابع خلال نصف ساعه القادمه هذه
الاجتماعات امام سينتج عنها من وارسم موفد
العربيه حسين قنيبل شكرا جزيلا لك
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الكويت تغربل المجمعات التجاريه ازمه سوق
شرق تتجدد والحكومه تتسلم مجمع المثلث
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت السعوديه عن
وديعه جديده للبنك المركزي اليمني بمليار
دولار سجل او سجل الريال اليمني مشاهدينا
في تعاملاته امس تحسنا متسارعا مقابل
العملات الاجنبيه حيث انخفض سعر الدولار
من 1300 الى 1200 ريال يمني وسط امال
باستقرار العمله ياتي ذلك في وقت تكافح به
الحكومه اليمنيه ضعف العمله وارتفاع اسعار
الوقود والسلع الاوليه ومواجهه انعدام
الامن الغذائي في البلاد
[موسيقى]
دعم سعودي مستمر لليمن دون تمييز هذا ما
تؤكد عليه الرياض طوال عقود وتشير بيانات
منصه المساعدات السعوديه الى ان قيمه
الدعم المقدم من السعوديه الى اليمن خلال
العقود الماضيه تجاوز 20 مليار دولار
بالامس اعلنت السعوديه عن تغذيه البنك
المركزي اليمني بوديعه قدرها مليار دولار
لتاتي هذه الوديعه مكمله لاربعه مليارات
دولار من الودائع منذ العام 2012
ومسانده لمجلس القياده الرئاسي لتمكينه من
ممارسه مهامه في تحقيق الامن والاستقرار
في اليمن
ذراعان اغاثيان سعوديان قدمها لليمن مئات
المشاريع التنمويه خلال السنوات الماضيه
الاول مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه الذي نفذ
759 مشروعا انسانيا واغاثيا وتنمويا في
اليمن بقيمه تجاوزت اربعه مليارات دولار
فيما نفذ البرنامج السعودي لتنميه واعمار
اليمن
224 مشروعا استفاد منها سته ملايين مواطن
في اربعه عشره محافظه يمنيه بنحو
828 مليون دولار هذه المشاريع مشاهدينا
والدعم ايضا كذلك الكبير جعلت السعوديه في
صداره قائمه الدول الالماني حال اليمن منذ
العام 2001 وحتى اللحظه وحول المعاناه
المستمره للشعب اليمني اكدت السعوديه على
اهميه قيام الدول الشقيقه والصديقه لليمن
بالمشاركه في تقديم الدعم لرفع المعاناه
عن الاشقاء اليمنيين
سعوديه سيكون لها دور كبير جدا في العمل
على تحقيق الاستقرار الاقتصادي والعمل على
تحسين قيمه العملات الوطنيه كونها اتت في
ظل ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه وديعه السعوديه
عاده الامان للشعب اليمني واعاده
اراده وتعتبر للحكومه دافع قوي لمواجهه
التحديات الذي يفرضها الجانب الحوثي على
الحكومه اليمنيه وعلى الشعب اليمني
بالنسبه الوديعه السعوديه
كانحل مناسب في الوقت المناسب خاصه في ظل
تدهور الحياه المعيشيه لدى المواطنين
نتمنى قياده الحكومه ان توظف هذه الوديعه
التوظيف السليم
وان تسعى بشكل جدي
وضع معالجات مستدامه
لانتعش الاقتصاد ويضم الينا في الاستوديو
السفير السعودي
بدايه ادعنا نتحدث عن تفاصيل عن اهميه هذه
الوديعه السعوديه للبنك المركزي اليمني
بمليار دولار كيف يمكن النظر اليها شكرا
لكم الله يحفظكم الحقيقه الوديعه هي جزء
من حزمه من الدعم التنموي والاقتصادي
للاشقاء في اليمن
هو مجموعه من الدعم تتكامل مع البعض في
خدمه الانسان اليمني وخدمه الاقتصاد
اليمني ودعم مجلس القياده الرئاسه اليمني
ليقوم بدوره هو والحكومه اليمنيه في خدمه
الانسان اليمني ومواجهه التحديات الصعبه
التي حقيقه يعانون منها بشكل كبير جدا
فالحزمه مكونه من مليار دولار من المملكه
ومليار دولار من الامارات المملكه او دعت
بالامس مليار دولار في البنك المركزي
اليمني وهذا سيساعد في دعم الاقتصاد
استقرار صعب سعر الصرف هذا سيساعد ايضا
التجار والرجال الاعمال في القدره على
الشراء واستيراد وخاص المواد الغذائيه
الاساسيه لو نظرت لعمرك للوديعه السابقه
2018 مليار دولار كان لها دور كبير في
مساعده استقرار سعر الصرف الريال اليمني
وايضا شراء المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه
للشعب اليمني عن طريق التجار رجال الاعمال
واستقرار السوق وبالتالي يتمكن من عمل
الدوره الاقتصاديه المتكامله الدعم ايضا
في مشتقات نفطيه هناك منحه مشتقات نفطيه
المرحله الثانيه المرحله الاولى كانت ب
420 مليون انتهت قبل سته اشهر واستكملنا
المرحله الثانيه
بتوفير مشتقات نفطيه لتشغيل محطات
الكهرباء في عموم المناطق الخاطئه على
السلطه الحكومه اليمنيه هذه ليست مجرد
تشغيل محطات كهربا هي اكبر من ذلك هي
تساعد الحكومه في عدم شراء
المشتقه النفطيم الخارج وبالتالي لن تسعى
الحصول على الدولار وبالتالي في استقرار
سعر صرف الريال ثم ايضا سيسهم في توفير
الكهرباء لكل القطاعات المختلفه في اليمن
وبالتالي ساهمنا عن طريق هذه الحزمه في
المساعده الحكومه هناك ايضا
مبادره اخرى وهي صندوق مستدام لشراء
وتوفير المشتقات النفطيه للسوق اليمني هذا
يساعد الحكومه اليمنيه في عدم وجود
مضاربين على الدولار لانه التاجر عندما
يحضر المشتقات النفطيه لليمن يبحث عن
الدولار في السوق المحليه شراء دفعه
الثانيه بالتالي اذا تمكنا من تمويل
الحكومه اليمنيه في صندوق مشتقات نفطيه
دوار بحيث تستطيع ان يشترى ويباع بسعر
ايضا ثابت ومستق في استقرار الدولار
بالاضافه مليار دولار التي ابدعتها مملكه
وهناك ايضا مليار دولار لدى الامارات اودع
منها مبلغ في حساب البنك المركزي بالاضافه
الى المشتقات النفطيه من عندنا اضافه الى
المشتقات النفديه وصندوق المشتقات ايضا
تكتمل الحزمه ب 400 مليون دولار مشاريع
تنمويه مختلفه منها محطات غاز لتبديل
الكهرباء في عدن عبر مشروع مشروع البرنامج
السعودي لتنميه العماره اليمن
في
للكهرباء تقريبا اربعه مشاريع في عدن
ومحيطها وكذلك المياه محطه تحليه مياه
وايضا تعزيز مصادر الطاقه المياه وهناك
مستشفى المكلف مستشفى كبير جدا
سيبدا تقريبا خلال شهر او شهرين البدء في
ترسيه المشروع هناك ايضا كليه الطب كليه
الصيدله وكليه التمريض في في تعز وطريقه
العبد بالاضافه الى طريق العبر مجموعه من
المشاريع الكبيره التي ستساعد ان شاء الله
في خدمه الانسان اليمني ادعم اقتصادي ودعم
ما وديعه وكذلك اهتمام حتى بادق التفاصيل
ساعه السفير في في الامور حتى الصحيه وحتى
امور التعليم وغيرها اسال هنا عن هذا
التزامن الدعم مع هذه الوديعه ايضا
انعكاسا على عمل مجلس القياده والرئاسه
قياده الماده الرئاسه اليمني كيف تتوقعون
حيكون الاثر هو التوقع لكل اثرها كبير جدا
في مساعدتهم في تحمل اعباء الدوله وتحمل
اعباء الكبيره جدا التي تنوء فيها الحكومه
اليمنيه ومشرقية الرئاسي لكن انا اريد ان
اذكر بان المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
عقود تدعم الاشقاء في اليمن دعم الشقيق
للشقيق دعم الواجب تجاهل اخيه
وللتذكير في عندما انتقلت السلطه في عام
2012 دعمت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بمليار دولار وديع البنك المركزي و3 مليار
و250 مليون دولار مشتقات نفطيه وتقرابه
الثلاثه مليار مشاريع مختلفه هو 2012
مليار 2018 مليارين
وهذه الدعوم الحقيقه المملكه
والتحالف يركزون على دعم الدوله لو لا
يمكن هناك دوله وحكومه بنك مركزي تابع
لدوله سيكون من الصعب تقديم دعم تنموي او
دعم اقتصادي فبظل وجود هذه القياده مجلس
القياده الرئاسي ظل وجود الحكومه اليمنيه
وسعها للتغلب على التحديات التي تواجهها
حاليا سواء كان في قدراتها او في مؤسساتها
او في الكبشه اللازمه لها الا ان هذا
سيساعدها ان شاء الله في تخطي كل الصعوبات
ونرجو ايضا هذا يساهم في دعم كل الاشقاء
في اليمن ولو تعلم طال عمرك بالنسبه
للوديعه اللي في البنك المركزي في عدن هي
ليست خاصه بمنطقه معينه هي خاصه بكل اليمن
70% تقريبا من
المواد الغذائيه التي تم شرائها في العام
2018 و19 و20 من السعوديه كانت الى
المناطق الخاطعه لسلطه الحوثيين وبالتالي
فهي تخدم بالشعب اليمني والحكومه اليمنيه
هي حكومه لكل الشعب اليمني ذلك لا تمييز
ولا اقصاء لاي من الشعب اليمني هذه
الدعومات وخصوصا هذه الوديعه اسعد السفير
هل هي مشروطه بضمانات تتحدثون عن ضمانات
محاربه الفساد للحفاظ على استقرار
المؤسسات ايضا والتنميتها وحتى الوصول
للاهداف المنشوده لهذه الوديعه وحتى لي
منحه المشتقات النفطيه وحتى للمشاريع
التنمويه اللي عبر برنامج تنميه اعمار
اليمن الحقيقه الحكومه اليمنيه يعملون
بشكل واسع على مواجهه هذه التحديات كما
اشرتم اليها متعلق مكافحه الفساد سواء في
القضاء في النيابه العامه في تعزيز
جهاز مكافحه الفساد لكن هناك اجراءات
عملناها مع الحكومه اليمنيه بحيث يكون
هناك شيء اكبر من قضيه فقط مكافحه الفساد
هذا امر اساسي واصيل وهو احد الركائز
الاساسيه في تقديم هذه الوديعه بان لا
يكون هناك فساد استمرار وان تستخدم للشعب
اليمني وان تساهم في تعزيز الاحتياطات
للبنك المركزي اليمني لكن هناك مشروع
اصلاحات ناقشته الحكومه اليمنيه او قدمت
لصندوق العربي للنقد صندوق العربي للنقد
وصندوق لكل الدول العربيه ولديه مشاريع
كثيره مع اليمن من ضمنها بناء قدرات البنك
المركزي وبالتالي صندوق العربي النقد اتفق
مع الحكومه اليمنيه على صندوق على مشروع
اصلاحات مختلفه في السياسه الماليه
والسياسه النقديه وفي العديد من المشاريع
الاصلاح وبالتالي دخل في
في برامج اصلاح ستساعد البنك المركزي في
النهوض
بوضع الاقتصاد اليمني وبالسياسه النقديه
وبالتالي جزء من هذا العمل هو مكافحه
الارهاب ومكافحه غسيل مال وايضا مكافحه
الفساد ورفع قدرات الدوله
التواصلكم مع الحكومه اليمنيه في في هذه
المشاريع الاصلاحيه المهمه
السفير هل بداوا فيها هل وصلوا فيها الى
مرحله متقدمه لمستموها انتم في الفتره
الماضيه لاحظنا زياده في قدره الحكومه على
زياده الايرادات وضبط البنك المركزي بشكل
افضل هناك جهود كبيره جدا لمواجه التحديات
المخ في قدرات القدرات ضعيفه جدا وبالتالي
يحاولون زياده بناء القدرات لدينا مشروع
في البرنامج السعودي يتم استعمار اليمن
بالتنسيق مع الحكومه اللبنيه لبناء قدرات
المؤسسات الاساسيه مساعدتها في النهوض
وايضا هناك بناء قدرات من البنك الدولي
صندوق النقد الدولي للاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا
العديد من الدول لمساعده الحكومه اليمنيه
في بناء قدراتها موجه التحديات الاقتصاديه
والماليه لكن من يتابع ومن يعمل مع البنك
المركزي اليمني هو صندوق العربي النقد
بموجب الاتفاق بموجب العلاقه بين الطرفين
ونحن نقدم التمويل وصندوق العربي النقد هو
من يساهم ويتابع في عمل الاصلاحات
البرنامج التي تقومون عليه برنامج تنميه
واعمار اليمن ساعه السفير هناك 17 مشروعا
تنمويا تم الاعلان عنها الفتره الاخيره
كانت متزامنه مع منحه المشتقات النفطيه
اذا ما خانتني الذاكره اللي كانت على
مرحلتين ايضا المشاريع التنمويه هناك اين
وصلت هل هناك مشاريع ايضا حتى قريبه سعاده
السفير
نعم اول شيء طال عمرك الحمد لله احنا من
منتصف 2018 منذ انشاء البرنامج بتوجيه
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين سيدي سمول
العهد واس الوزراء البرنامج ينفذ مشاريع
كبيره جدا ومختلفه جدا في عدد المحافظات
عندنا 224 مشروع 52 مشروع تعليمي سلم 27
مدرسه
جامعه سبا انشاء لها قاعات وتم تاثها
جامعه عدن وكذلك هناك مشاريع اخرى في مجال
التعليم كذلك 38 مشروع في النقل فلدينا
طعم مطار عدن مطار الغيظه وايضا العديد من
المطارات تطورنا فيها واوساهمنا في تعزيز
قدراتها طريق العبر 160 كيلو متر وهو طريق
يسمونه الاخوه اليمنيين طريق الموت يتسبب
في كثيرا من
الحوادث الاشقاء وهناك عمرك 31 مشروع في
الصحه ولعل المشروع مستشفى تشغيل عدن وهو
مستشفى المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعدنا
تاهيله خلال الفتره الماضيه وبدانا في
التشغيل 270 سرير منها خمسين سرير للقلب
وبدانا ولله الحمد الاطباء يمنيين واجانب
العربيه السعوديه ويعمل الان في عدن قاموا
بعمليات
قلب ناجحه لاطفال ونساء ورجال وسيتتح ان
شاء الله قريبا فخامه الرئيس اليمني بحول
الله وايضا ثلاثين مشروع في مجال المياه
مختلفه الانواع
18 مشروع في مجال الزراعه السمكيه 11
مشروع للبناء ودعم المؤسسات الحكوميه
وتقريبا 29 مشروع المجال الطاقه من ضمنها
منحه المشتقات النفطيه وكذلك 12 برنامج
تنموي هذه المشاريع الحقيقه ساهمت في جلب
المنظمات الدوليه استطعنا ان نقنع المجتمع
الدولي التحول من الاغاثه الى التنميه
وقدمنا نموذج جديد على مستوى العالم كيف
يمكن ان ندعم الحكومات في وقت الصراع كما
فعلنا مع الحكومه اليمنيه حاليا ونرجو ان
شاء الله انها تصل الى المناطق في حال ان
شاء الله الوصول للسلام بالتوفيق لكم ان
شاء الله شكرا لك على حضورك معي هنا في
استوديو نشره الرابعه السفير السعودي لدى
اليمن محمد الجابر شكرا لك شكرا يعطيك
العافيه
نتابع اخبار بارزه من الكويت وتطورات
دراماتيكيه في نزاع الوطنيه العقاريه
وزاره الماليه الكويتيه بشان طبعا سوق شرق
حيث تتمسك الوطنيه العقاريه بتجديدها لعقد
ايجار الارض المقام عليها المجمع مع املاك
الدوله بينما تريد وزاره الماليه تسليم
المجمع بحجه انتهاء عقد الايجار ما حصل
اليوم هو لجوء موظفي وزاره الماليه
الكويتيه الى الشرطه لاثبات حاله امتناع
الشركه عن تنفيذ قرار اداره املاك الدوله
بما اكدت الوطنيه العقاريه في افصاح
البورصه استمرارها باستغلال المجمع
العقد المبرم في ما بين الشركه الوطنيه
العقاريه اللي هي تدير سوق شرق هو عقد
ساري ومستمر ودلاله ذلك جمله من المسائل
اهمها بانه
اداره سوق شرق ممثله بالشركه الوطنيه
العقاريه عندما تم الانتهاء من العقد في
سنه 2018 قام قامت وزاره الماليه ممثله
باداره املاك الدوله بارسال مجموعه من
المخاطبات اهمها اليه تجديد العقد مع
الشركه الوطنيه العقاريه وعندما وقعت
جائحه كورونا في سنه 2019 قامت وزاره
الماليه بارسال كتاب تنفيذا لرغبات مجلس
الوزراء الموقر
باعفاء الشركات من الاجره في ذلك الوقت
وتم ارسال كتاب من قبل وزاره الماليه
ممثله باداره املاك الدوله الى الشركه
الوطنيه العقاريه باعتبارها من تدير هذا
العقار او هذا المشروع وتم اعفائها بفتره
كورونا وبالتالي هذا يثير تساؤل في غايه
الاهميه اذا احنا عقدنا في النهايه غير
مجدد وغير مستمر لماذا تخاطبنا وزاره
الماليه اداره املاك الدوله وتشير بانه لا
يتم تجديد العقد اذا انا عقد مجدد لماذا
انت تعفيني من الاجره
ومن جانب اخر اعلنت وزاره الماليه
الكويتيه عن تسلمها عقار مجمع المثنى بناء
على حكم محكمه التمييز الصادر بتاريخ 23
من نوفمبر 2022 والذي الزم بيت التمويل
الكويتي باخلاء العقار وتسليمه لوزاره
الماليه وافادت وزاره الماليه الكويتيه
انها قامت بمخاطبه هيئه مشروعات الشراكه
بين القطاعين العام والخاص لطرح المشروع
في مزايده عامة
رابع مستمر وفيها بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
احتفاء شعبي رسمي بيوم التاسيس في
السعوديه اعتزاز بذكرى وتاريخ الدول
السعوديه الثلاث
قوه اسرائيليه تقتحم نابلس عشره قتلى ومئه
جريح فلسطيني على الاقل
انفراجه اقتصاديه في اليمن وديعه سعوديه
جديده بمليار دولار والريال اليمني يبدا
التعافي
الكويت تغربل المجمعات التجاريه ازمه سوق
شرق تتجدد والحكومه تتسلم مجمع المثنى
[موسيقى]
احتفاء شعبيون رسمي بيوم التاسيس في
السعوديه اعتزاز بذكرى وتاريخ الدول
السعوديه الثلاث
حياكم الله من جديد يحتفي السعوديون اليوم
وكل عام بذكرى يوم التاسيس الذي يوافق
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير يوثق هذا اليوم
رحله الدول السعوديه ثلاث طوالت طوال
ثلاثه قرون وصولا الى اليوم الذي نعيش فيه
حكم الدوله السعوديه الثالثه الزميل احمد
الهادي يعرفون اكثر على يوم التاسيس في
العرض التالي
ذكرى سنويه يحييها السعوديون كل عام
الاحتفاء بالثاني والعشرين من فبراير
باعتباره يوم تاسيس الدوله السعوديه على
يد الامام محمد بن سعود في العام
1139 للهجره اي
1727 للميلاد الامام محمد بن سعود
مشاهدينا بدا رحله التاسيس من الدرعيه
الواقع على ضفاف وادي حنيفه حيث وحد شطرها
رغبه في منحها مزيد من الاستقرار
باعتبارها واقعه على احد اهم طرق التجاره
قديما ليعمل امام محمد بن سعود على نشر
الاستقرار في المنطقه كما انطلقت تحت
قيادته حملات لتوحيد معظم منطقه نجد سنوات
تاسيس الاولى شهدت ايضا جهدا كبيرا لتامين
طرق الحج والتجاره حتى اصبحت نجد منطقه
امنه تماما للمريض عبرها سواء الحجاج
كانوا او قوافل بالاضافه الى تنظيم
العلاقات مع القبائل وتنظيم الشؤون
الاقتصاديه للدوله بعد تاسيس الدوله بنحو
18 عاما قدم الى الدرعيه الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الوهاب بناء على دعوه من الامام محمد
بن سعود الذي حماه وناصر دعوته الاصلاحيه
ما اسهم في تقويه الجوانب العلميه
والثقافيه للدوله وتطوير الجانب التعليمي
في الجزيره العربيه
الاعلان عن يوم التاسيس وتحديده باليوم
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير من كل عام يهدف
لوضع تاريخ سياسي دقيق لتاسيس الدوله
والتعريف ببدايتها لكنه لا يلغي رمزيه
الثالث والعشرون سبتمبر الذي تحتفي فيه
السعوديه كل عام بوصفه يوما وطنيا لتوحيد
الدوله الحديثه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
على يد مؤسسها الملك عبد العزيز
ومن فعاليه الايمان في الرياض ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز ومن مركز اعتراض
الظهران مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
حياكم الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
وخليني ابدا معك يا عبد الرحمن يعني بما
انك محتفي بهذا اليوم
باللباس اعتقد ان شرقاوي بس تقدر عبد
الرحمن تعرفنا عليه اكثر واشرح لنا ايضا
عن الصوره خلفك
هلا بك يا نايف طبعا كل عام وانتم بخير
اليوم المنطقه الشرقيه كلها في كل بقعه
هناك احتفال واحتفال بهذا اليوم العظيم
يوم تاسيس هذا الوطن الكبير والخالد
والباقي المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
انا نايف لابس العقال المقصب ولابس طبعا
الدقله ولابس الثوب المرودن هذا الزي
اجدادنا وابائنا طبعا الى جانب طبعا
المجند الذي كان يلبسه المقاتلين اثناء
المعارك قديما طبعا ومعي البندق
التقليدي الكلاسيكي القديم طبعا اليوم
مركز اثراء هنا في الظهران يقدم برنامج
متنوع وكبير ومميز جدا لزواره سادع زميلي
المصور نصر ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات ويريكم
الاجواء الاحتفاليه هنا في مركز اثنان
نشاهد الاطفال وهم يحتف ويتزينون بملابس
الوطنيه من كل منطقه نايف يعني الشرقيه
الجنوب المدينه المنوره نجران الشمال كل
الازياء التقليديه الوطنيه موجوده وحاضره
هنا بقوه اليوم صباحا ايضا كنا في الاحساء
في سوق القيصريه مع الزملاء في برنامج
صباح العربيه وايضا تخيل نايف من الساعه
ثمانيه صباحا الشباب طالعين للشوارع
يحتفلون
ويستمتعون بهذه الاجواء خاصه يا نايف انه
الحكومه اليوم في اجازه رسميه الى جانب
طبعا القطاع الخاص والشركات فالغالبيه في
اجازه ومبسوطين ومستمتعين بالاجواء واليوم
الحسن حظنا في المنطقه الشرقيه انه الجو
حلو والطقس جدا جدا مناسب نشاهد الان
العرضه السعوديه الشهيره ايضا
هذه الفرقه تقدم العروض منذ الساعه
الرابعه مساء حتى
الساعه العاشره ليلا في مركز اثراء
الثقافي طيب خلينا نروح لصوره اخرى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض نواف عزيز نواف
مرحبا بك معي ايضا في
هذا القسم من نشره طبعا انت اليوم مو لابس
ملابس التاسيس يا عبد الرحمن بشكل مختلف
طالع لكن قول لي فعاليه الليوان نواف عفوا
فعاليه اللوان ما هي فعاليه اليوم الذي
تحتويه ايضا
نعم نايف بين الابراج الشاهقه في مركز
الملك عبد الله المالي بالرياض انطلقت
فعاليه الليوان للتو وهي تشكل واحده من 14
فعاليه منتشره في مناطق المملكه للاحتفال
في يوم التاسيس وتستمر على مدى ثلاثه ايام
هذه الفعاليه كما سنشاهد الان تعبر عن
التراث والتاريخ للدوله السعوديه منذ
التاسيس حرف يدويه ايضا
عمليات اخرى ومعارض وعروض موسيقيه وفرق
جواله ترتدي الزي السعودي الاصيل كما
نشاهد الان خراز الاحذيه وهو ابو عبد
العزيز الخراز اهلا وسهلا ابو عبد العزيز
في البدايه كيف تتم صناعه الاحذيه قديما
باستخدام الجلود طبعا بعد دباغه الجلود
بناخذ
الجلد ونسوي منه المشغولات الجلديه
الاحذيه في مرحله من المراحل نسويها بعدين
تبدا الشنط بعدين يبدا اللي هي المجالد
وبيوت المسدسات والسكاكين هذه كلها
الزوار ماذا على ماذا يتعرفون عند هذه
الزياره المعرض الخاص بك طبعا الزوار يعني
يبحث عن التراث الصراحه يعني في حاجات ما
يعرفوها الان بعد من بعد يعني الكلمه اللي
احنا بنقدمها لهم
ونبدا التعريفيه البسيطه
وبياخذوا فكره حلوه الصراحه كل الشكر لك
يا ابو عبد العزيز اضافه الى وجود العديد
من المعارض الاخرى نايف حياكه السلوك كما
نشاهد في هذا المعرض
تتواجد فيه سيده وهي من الاسر المنتجه
والسد يعتبر ايضا يعني متعارف عليه كثيرا
في السعوديه ويروج له خلال الفتره الاخيره
بشكل كبير هذه الفعاليه من قبل وزاره
الثقافه تنظم وكما ذكرت هي في اربعه عشر
منطقه وتستمر على مدى ثلاثه ايام بتنوع
واسع عروض موسيقيه هو معارض تفاعليه
اشكركما جزيل الشكر من الرياض مراسل
العربيه نواف عزيز وكذلك ايضا من مركز
اثراب الظهران كان معنا ايضا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العثيم شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
تنطلقوا اليوم عروض المسرحيه الشعريه
الغنائيه معلقات امتداد وامجادنا امتداد
امجادنا وذلك احتفاء بيوم التاسيس السعودي
على مسرح جامعه الاميره نوره
وتستلهم المسرحيه تراث الجزيره العربيه
بوصفها امتداد الحضاره والحياه التي
انبعثت فشيدت الدوله السعوديه قبل ثلاثه
قرون حيث يجاري عشره شعراء معاصرين
المعلقات العشر الشهيره فتراث العربي
وتسرد
قصصهم تاسيس الدوله السعوديه الاولى
من المسرح الاحمر بجامعه الاميره نوره
ينضم الينا مخرج مسرحيه معلقاتنا امتداد
امجادنا عامر الحمود سيد عامر حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض سعيد
بانضمامك الينا في هذا القسم من النشره
مسرحيه شعريه غنائيه نريد ان نعرف
تفاصيلها اولا منك وكواليس هذا العمل ايضا
اللي انا اعرف انه انتم اخذتوا تقريبا
سنتين فيه حتى الان
مساء الخير نايف مساء الخير لجميع مشاهدين
قناه العربيه حياك الله برنامج الرابعه
اليوم ينطلق اول عرض للمسرحيه الشعريه
الغنائيه معلقات الامجاد ويستمر حتى يوم
27 ان شاء الله الساعه التاسعه مساء من كل
يوم المسرحيه هي فكره واشراف صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير عبد الرحمن المساعد
بدات الفكره فعلا من تقريبا قرابه السنتين
العمل المسرحي هذا
مخطط لان يكون هو من اهم الاعمال المسرحيه
السعوديه شكلا ومضمونا
وتم العمل على هذا الاساس المسرحيه كتبت
مجارات للمعلقات العشر
وهذا يعني ايضا
يعني يفيد بان امتدادنا من تلك الايام
[موسيقى]
اكثر من الف شخص تحدث عن الاجانب هنا
اول شيء يعني الشكر موصول لسمو وزير
الثقافه الامير بدر فرحان على الدعم لا
متناهي لهذا العمل
استعنا في فريق عمل متخصص في مجال مسرح من
برودي من امريكا وبريطانيا وايطاليا وكندا
والعديد من الدول
التي تم اختيارهم بعنايه يعني الحقيقه
اللي جو معانا في هذا العمل مش مجرد انه
احنا قلنا نبغى نسوي عمل مسرحي ونجيب فيه
اشخاص لا احنا تم البحث يعني كان فيصل
الحمود متخصص في مساله انه كيف يقدر يسقطب
هذا الفريق اللي ممكن يحقق لنا اهدافنا في
هذا في الرؤيه نفسها وانتقال المسرح
السعودي من محطه الى محطه اخرى فكان كان
كان الفريق العمل
قدم عديد من الاعمال المسرحيه في بلدانهم
منها اعمال مسرحيه لا زالت تعرض الى يومنا
هذا في هذه البلدان وصار لها سنوات كبيره
اذا ما كانت فقط ان نقدم عمل مسرح يسبب
اذا كانت ايضا ان يكون هناك متدربين معانا
من هيئه المسرح فنون الادائيه 45 متدرب
عشان يستفيدوا من هذه الادارات من هذه
الاقسام من الاضاءه الصوت
كل عناصر العمل
وايضا
انا بتكلم هناك كواحد مخرج والرجل المهم
يعني
التحدي الاساسي كان هي مسجد ثقافات في هذا
المجال يعني انت كيف تقدر تستقطب فريق عمل
من خارج المملكه روع هذا الفريق الى ثقافه
ثقافتك انت يعني تنقل
الامكانيات والقدرات اللي موجوده وتحاول
من خلال هذه الامكانيات تسخرها لعملك
الحقيقه كانت في البدايه كانت هناك بعض
بعض النقاشات الكثيره يعني فهمت علي لانه
احنا لنا خصوصيتنا في مسرحنا لنا شكلنا
وبعدين ما نبغى احنا نقدم شيء مستنسخ انا
تقدم تجربه سعوديه عالميه بمواصفات عالميه
فهذه الحقيقه اللي هي كانت الموجه ايضا
انه كان التحدي عند الامير عبد الرحمن انه
كيف يقدر يوفر مطربين
يقدمون عمل ويشتغلون بروفات لمده شهر انت
تعرف المطربين دائما يعني عندهم
التزاماتهم عندهم حفلاتهم عندهم وانت عارف
السعوديه نشطه فبالتالي راح الى منطقه
يعني اخرى اللي هي المطربين الشباب اللي
ممكن فعلا يكونون هو نواه لعمل متميز
ومختلف وايضا اعتقد انه دور الامير عبد
الرحمن مساعد بانه كيف يقدر يقدم جيل جديد
من خلال هذا العمل وبالفعل انا اعتقد اللي
حيشاهد المسرحيه حيشوف اصوات في منتهى
الجمال والروعه والحقيقه يستحقون ان يقفون
على هذا المسرح ان شاء الله نشوفها قريبا
العروض من اليوم تقريبا ليله وحتى تستمر
حتى انطلاقه اليوم ان شاء الله الساعه
التاسعه واثنين حتى الجمعه القادمه
باذن واحد احد احنا احنا ندعوك وندعو
الجميع الحقيقه
العظيمه يوم التاسيس وان شاء الله ان تكون
هذه تكون هذه المسرحيه هي تحقيق رؤيه سمو
سيدي ولي العهد في هذا المجال الثقافي
المهم
المجال المسرحي يعطيك العافيه بالتوفيق
لكم ان شاء الله بانتظار طبعا بدايه
العروض لهذه المسرحيه من المس الاحمر
بجامعه الامير نوره انضم الينا مخرج
مسرحيه معلقات هنا امتداد وامجاد السيد
عامر الحمود شكرا لك
شكرا لزميل محمد القناص نذهب لمشاهده هذه
الصور المباشره لبدايه اجتماعات لبدايه
اجتماعات مجموعه بوخارست 9 مع الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وتظهر ربما هنا صوره
الرئيس
البولندي القمه التي
يعني عقدت يوم امس مع الرئيس البولندي
والرئيس الامريكي
سبقها زياره مهمه للرئيس جو بايدن الى
كييف والان بدايه اجتماع بوخارست تسعه
نستمع
يجتمع مجددا في صيغه مجموعه
بوخارست التي اطلقتها في عام 2015 مع
الرئيس دوده
بمناسبه
عوده الحربي الى اوروبا هذه الحرب التي
جلبت المعاناه
والبؤس والقتل ونزوح الملايين من
الاوكرانيين ودمار غير مسبوق وغموض كبير
نحن قاده الجناحه الشرقي علينا مسؤوليه
الوقوف معا للدفاع عن امننا
وسلام يجب ان نواصل الوفاء بالتزاماتنا
لدعم اوكرانيا
طالما احتاجت لذلك
الانتصار في هذه الحرب هذا ما ستواصل
القيام به ونحن لسنا بمفردنا
جهودنا
هي في اطار الاتحاد او حلف الاطلسي ارحب
اليوم بحضور الرئيس جوزيف بايدن وهذا يعيد
تاكيد على جوهر صيغه بوخارست وكذلك
التزام الاداره الامريكيه تجاه امن الجناح
الشرقي للحلف
ان هذا الالتزام قوي للغايه ويتطلع الى
المستقبل من خلال زياده الوجود العسكري
الامريكي
والاستعداد الاستراتيجيه امريكيه للبحر
الاسود ارحب ايضا
بمشاركه امين عام النيتو يانس
لاغراض التنسيق وقبل نحو عام حاولت روسيا
تدمير الانف في اوروبا
النظام الدولي القائم على القواعد وروسيا
تتصرف
بلد معتدي وقد شهدنا ذلك في جمهوريه
مولدوفا وفي جورجيا وكذلك في اوكرانيا
ذاتها
اليوم هؤلاء شركاء يستفيدون من دعم الحلف
للقدره على الصمود على المدى البعيد وهذا
ضروري حتى يحققوا سلاما واستقرار وازدهار
مستديما نحن ندعم بقوه ايضا
[موسيقى]
الامين العام للحلف ايها الحلفاء الاعزاء
كما شرت السيد الرئيس نلتقي اليوم في
اوقات خاصه
تصادف الذكرى الاولى لعدوان روسيا على
اوكرانيا
هذا العام جعلنا اقوى واكثر وحده نحن
البلدان في الجناح الشرقي نحضب حمايه اكبر
من اي وقت مضى ومعا نجحنا في اختبار
التضامن والانسانيه من خلال دعمنا
لاوكرانيا الرئيس بايدن حضوركم اليوم دليل
اخر بان وحدتنا الاطلسيه اقوى من اي وقت
مضى وهي فرصه تسمح لنا بمناقشه توقعاتنا
من قمه النيتو في فيديو على سبيل المثال
كيف يمكن ان نضم ان يكون هناك اي اماكن
رماديه في دفاعنا كيف يمكن ان اقلم دفاعنا
او انفاقنا الدفاع بشان بيئتنا الامنيه
وكيف يمكن نضمن قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع
النفسيه طالما احتاج لذلك كيف يمكن ان
نتحرك او نعزز العلاقات بين النيتو وروسيا
هذا نناقشه اليوم وكذلك في قمه
براتيسلافيا في يونيو في فيديو يوسفي
يوليو اشكركم فخامه رئيس دوده على
استضافتنا اتطلع لمناقشاتنا شكرا شكرا
فخامه الرئيسه اصحاب الفخامه الاصدقاء
الاعزاء نحن سعداء جدا ان يكون بيننا
اليوم ضيف خاص
قبل الدعوه الى قمه رئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه السيد جوزيف بايدن اهلا وسهلا
بك سيدي واعطيك الكلمه شكرا جزيلا لكم
شكرا جزيلا وانا سعيد انا تواجده هنا قد
تتذكرون
قبل سنوات
عندما كنا نوسع النيتو
وسخريه القدر هي انه
ما تذكره
فيما يخص صديقينا في روسيا
هو انني قلت لها انك تطالب دائما
لفلندت النيت
وسوف تحصل على انضمامي في ماذا حدث
فنحن اقوى مما كنا عليه
وقلت
ليقول لي الرؤساء اننا هنا معكم
كحلفاء اقوياء في النيت
والامين العام برايي انجز عملا رائعا
لفتره طويله واعول على حكمه كثيرا ان
مجموعه الدول التسعه انشات في عام 2015
ليس بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فحسب ولكن لحريه
الديمقراطيات في اوروبا والعالم
وقد تحدثت عن هذا الامر مع الرئيس لينسكي
عندما زرت كيف قبل يومين والقاده
المجتمعون حول هذه الطاوله اكدوا التزامنا
المشترك تجاه كل هذه القيم وقدمنا مساعده
امنيه حاسمه لاوكرانيا ودعم حاسم للملايين
من اللاجئين وضمناهم حصول اوكرانيا او
الاوكرانيين على الخدمات الاساسيه ومعا
سنواصل تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا بينما تدافع
عن حريتها خلال العام المنصر
بفضل تقديمكم لدور ريادي عززنا ايضا النيت
والتزام الولايات المتحده والنيت وقلت ذلك
لكم مرار وتكرار واكرر ذلك الان هذا واضح
كل وضوح
الماده الخامسه هي التزام مقدس بالنسبه
للالويات المتحده سوف ندافع عن كل شبر من
اراضي الدول النيت وفي هذه اللحظه المهمه
تطلع
لمناقشاتنا والخطوات اللاحقه التي سوف
نتخذها لابقاء حلفنا قوي لردع اي عدوان
اخر ما هو علم بحق ليست اوكرانيا وانما
الحريه
وفكره انها اكثر من الف عنصر
يهاجمون بلد بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الامور تغيرت بشكل جذري وعلينا ان نتاكد
من اننا نتصدى لذلك شكرا جزيلا لكم على
دعوه وتطلعوا لمناقشاتنا
شكرا جزيلا السيد رئيس اعطي الكلمه الان
الى امين عام حلف شمال الاطلس السيد يونس
شكرا
انا سعيد ان اعود الى وارسو لالتيقا
برؤساء الدول وحكومات مجموعه بوخارست
والرئيس بايدن جو اريد ان اقول لك
انني سعيد جدا
لما تقومون بهم بدور الرياضي وزيارتك
لكييف ابعثت بعثت برساله قويه رساله دعم
لاوكرانيا وكذلك التزام
اليات المتحده الذي لا تزعزع اتجاه امني
اوروبا اشكرك ايضا على استضافه قمه النيتو
المقبل بعد قمه يونس في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
عام مدام منذ اطلاق روسيا لغزوها ورئيس
بوتس مستعد
للسلام هو يستعد للمزيد من لذلك يجب ان
نواصل التقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا ونعطي
اوكرانيا ما تحتاج اليه لتنتصر لا نعلم
متى سوف تنتهي الحرب ولكن عندما يحدث ذلك
يجب ان نضمن ان التاريخ لن يعيد نفسه ولقد
شهدنا نسق الروسي للعدوان على مدى سنوات
روسيا في جورجيا عام 2008 والقرم ودومباس
في 2014 ثم الغزو الكامل لاوكرانيا العام
الماضي لا يمكن لن يسمح لروسيا
بمواصله
التاثير على الامن الاوروبي
يجب ان نكسر دائره العدوان الروسي حلفاء
النيتو لم يكونوا اكثر وحده مما هم عليه
نحن نحمي كل شبر من اراضي النيتو على اساس
الالتزام بموجب الماده الخامسه ان ندافع
عن بعضنا البعض شكرا جزيل شكرا معالي
الامين العام ايها الساده والسيدات هكذا
نصل الى ختام هذه الجلسه المفتوحه لوسائل
الاعلام اود ان اطلب منكم التفضل بمغادره
القاعه شكرا